Trascrizione: Valentina Franzoni
Revisore: Stefania Recchia
Buonasera a tutti.
Innanzitutto volevo dire che per me
è un onore essere qui
e chiudere questa giornata.
La mia formazione è un misto
di sociologia e di informatica.
A prima vista può sembrare
una strana commistione,
ma ultimamente qualcosa è cambiato
e mi ha permesso
di mettere assieme le due cose,
finalmente.
Nel talk di oggi vi presento
un approccio analitico e metodologico,
che io applico nel talk di oggi
ai dati estratti dai social network,
ma comunque ha un utilizzo trasversale,
che va dall'analisi
in Scienze dell'Educazione
fino ad applicazioni più evolute
in campo genetico
e fa leva appunto su quell'enorme
mole di dati presenti nel Web
e affonda radici nel tempo molto indietro,
ma rivive di una nuova vitalità
con l'avvento del Web 2.0,
quindi con la creazione in autonomia
di contenuti da parte di un'audience
che fino alla creazione prima dei blog,
poi dei social network,
era un'audience silente,
poi invece ha cominciato a interagire
prima con i contenuti e poi
interagire con altre persone
e a creare appunto
una enorme mole di dati,
che può essere sintetizzata,
visualizzata ed analizzata in molti modi.
Io vi presento un approccio
che si chiama Social Network Analysis.
Ma andiamo per ordine.
Troviamo il filo rosso che congiunge
questi 3 personaggi.
Partiamo, diciamo, da quello noto ai più:
all'estrema destra
abbiamo Mark Zuckerberg,
padre fondatore di Facebook,
informatico statunitense.
Facebook appunto che quest'anno
ha compiuto, recentemente anche,
il decimo anno dalla sua fondazione.
Ho portato lui diciamo
come personaggio noto
e come rappresentante
di tutto il mondo dei social a 360°,
anche se poi parleremo anche
di altri social network,
soprattutto di Twitter.
Percorrendo a ritroso,
abbiamo Jacob Levi Moreno,
che è uno psichiatra statunitense,
che è stato il primo
a parlare di sociogramma,
quindi della possibilità di rappresentare
le relazioni tra persone
tramite un grafico, tramite una rete.
Senza il contributo di Leonhard Euler,
che è un matematico e fisico svizzero,
che vedete rappresentato
all'estrema sinistra,
mi piace pensare che tutto ciò
non potesse avere un seguito.
Mi spiego.
Lui è, tra le varie cose, il padre
della teoria dei grafi,
che è la base matematica,
oltre che della Social network Analysis,
anche della topologia.
Ma, per ordine, cito un contributo
di Jacob Levi Moreno.
Lui nel 1934 è stato il primo,
con un disegno a mano,
che io ho riprodotto in modo digitale
a rappresentare le relazioni
all'interno dei gruppi
con il cosiddetto sociogramma
e il suo è un lavoro
peculiare, pionieristico,
nell'ambito appunto
delle Scienze dell'Educazione.
Lui ha rappresentato le relazioni amicali
all'interno di una scuola elementare.
In questo grafo i maschi sono i triangoli,
le femmine sono i cerchi.
Esiste una relazione, quindi una connessione,
quindi un arco,
usando il gergo
della Social Network Analysis,
quando questi bambini hanno dichiarato
un legame di amicizia.
Quindi esiste un legame
di amicizia esplicito, dichiarato,
quando un cerchio è collegato
ad un triangolo e viceversa.
Quando il trattino è interrotto da una barra,
vuol dire che questo legame è reciproco.
Questo tipo di approccio,
questo tipo di analisi
risulta enormemente attuale,
enormemente utile per rappresentare
le relazioni tra persone nei social network
ed anche le relazioni tra contenuti,
come vedremo.
Termini come attori, nodi, community,
sub-community, essere isolati,
essere influenti,
essere più o meno centrali
all'interno di una comunità
sono sorprendentemente attuali,
se vengono applicati al mondo dei social.
Esistono prodotti, software, open source
alla portata di tutti,
che permettono di estrarre
i dati dei social network
e di rappresentarli tramite grafo.
Dico alla portata di tutti,
perché attualmente
sto sperimentando l'adozione
di questi strumenti in una scuola media,
in collaborazione
con gli insegnanti chiaramente,
come ausilio all'utilizzo,
diciamo, del computer
e come appoggio all'insegnamento
della matematica.
Qui ad esempio vedete un grafo
estratto da Facebook, che rappresenta
la rete delle relazioni amicali
tra le mie connessioni Facebook.
Mi spiego. Ogni nodo,
quindi ogni cerchio, rappresenta un amico.
I nodi, quindi i cerchi,
sono collegati da un arco
quando a loro volta sono amici.
Usando, appunto, opportuni software,
è possibile spazializzare,
quindi distribuire in uno spazio fisico,
i nodi a seconda della densità dei legami,
dare dei colori, usando degli algoritmi
di community detection,
che vanno ad identificare le sub-community
all'interno di questo grafo.
Mi spiego, in blu sono rappresentati,
ad esempio, i miei amici di università,
in rosso i miei parenti, in verde
è l'ecosistema degli amici
e colleghi delle startup,
in viola invece troviamo
le connessioni in ambito lavorativo.
Chiaramente, dietro
ad ogni nodo c'è un nome,
che io non visualizzo per privacy
ed anche per economia di visualizzazione.
I nodi possono essere enfatizzati,
in termini di diametro in questo caso,
a seconda dell'importanza
per la community di riferimento.
Vedete, i nodi più grandi
sono quelli più centrali
all'interno della community di pertinenza.
Non solo Facebook,
ma anche Twitter dicevamo,
altro social network
in auge e in crescita.
Mi sono divertito ad esempio
ad estrarre tutte le conversazioni
attorno ad un termine,
penso condiviso anche dalla platea,
ho visto le parole
segnate sui vostri badge,
che è il termine "startup".
Questa è la sintesi
delle conversazioni Twitter
attorno al termine "startup"
raccolta nelle ultime due settimane.
Parliamo di qualche migliaio di tweet
e come nell'esempio precedente,
ogni nodo, quindi ogni pallino,
è un utente,
quindi una persona che ha twittato,
che può essere o meno in connessione
con un'altra, se entra in interazione.
Quindi, vuol dire se menziona
oppure twitta un'altra persona.
Entrando nel cuore del grafico,
mentre sulla corona esterna prima vedevamo
delle comunità disconnesse,
quindi persone che hanno twittato
senza entrare in connessione con nessuno
oppure essendo poco riprese,
il cuore centrale del grafico,
con la stessa logica, permette di indagare
quali sono le sotto-community
di riferimento,
quali sono gli influencer
all'interno delle comunity
e ad esempio indirizzare ulteriori azioni,
quindi si parla non solo di ricerca
ma di applicazione ad esempio
al marketing o altro.
Un altro esempio sempre mutuato
da Twitter è questa rete di hashtag.
Gli hashtag sono utilizzati in Twitter,
chiaramente con una valenza
fortemente evocativa,
di sintesi e vanno a sottendere
un più ampio mondo di significati.
Sono dei meta-marcatori, lasciatemi dire.
Quindi, attorno appunto, come dicevamo,
al termine "startup"
vediamo gli altri hashtag
usati in concomitanza,
nello stesso tweet.
Questo grafo va letto in questo modo:
il nodo ha una dimensione
tanto più ampia
tanto più è frequente l'utilizzo.
Chiaramente il termine "startup"
è stato usato sempre,
perché è stato il mio filtro di ricerca
ed è in collegamento con un altro nodo
quando c'è stata una co-occorrenza,
quindi la presenza di due stessi termini
nello stesso tweet.
Questo aiuta ad individuare
i cluster tematici, vedete i diversi colori,
e anche i temi utilizzati in abbinata
e gli argomenti più frequenti e ricorrenti.
Vedete citati termini
che hanno a che fare
con la tecnologia, lo sviluppo software,
sistemi di finanziamento,
vedo crowdfunding o altro
e anche con le location
che hanno maggiormente a che fare
con le startup,
perché offrono un ecosistema privilegiato,
vuoi per motivi fiscali
o per programmi diciamo dedicati,
quindi vedo Londra,
vedo Dubai e altro.
Ecco, per chiudere il cerchio
vi porto una suggestione e alcuni scatti
fatti in una scuola materna,
dove appunto
ha trovato applicazione, diciamo,
questa teoria e questa metodologia.
Ai bambini di questa scuola materna
è stato chiesto di ritrarsi con un disegno,
vedete sulla sinistra due disegni appunto
di due bambini,
di diverse età evidentemente,
poi di sedersi attorno ad un cartellone,
seduti dietro al proprio disegno
con un gomitolo di filo in mano,
tenendone un capo
e di lanciare il gomitolo a un amico.
Questo fino a coprire
tutti i disegni presenti.
Il risultato di questo esercizio
è quello che in questa scuola
hanno chiamato
"La ragnatela dell'amicizia",
e lo vedete qui proiettato
alle vostre spalle.
Questa è la ragnatela totale,
diciamo il disegno a fondo bianco,
poi ad ogni bambino è stato chiesto
di concentrarsi
sulla propria ragnatela personale.
È inutile che vi dica che i miei due figli
erano seduti attorno a quel cartellone
e hanno contribuito sicuramente
a ispirarmi per questo talk.
Spero che abbiano ispirato anche voi.
Ho finito, grazie.
(Applausi)